tell us what you want carved an
eco-friendly can I better not see the
flash either
[Music]
gotta go faster when you try to say
getting flash
[Music]
I mean lady
I'd like to smash them to peace I'll be
ready
[Music]
believes in the impossible possible
that's impossible well I am the
impossible
[Music]
hey everybody surprised new flash
trailer I didn't expect them to drop new
footage till next week they sort of mix
some old stuff with some new stuff so
there is a new round of that flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter
just be a subscriber and leave a comment
on the video but in addition to this new
flash footage we also learned about some
new stuff happening on Titans they
confirmed that the Doom Patrol is coming
so I'll explain what's going on with
that after we talk about new flash dub
but you get a couple new shots of Barry
SuperSpeed putting cuffs on the meta
from next week the Fiddler's that's what
I'm calling her they might give her that
name at the end of the episode but
because of the footage that we've seen
so far they've also dropped some promo
images two of them just watching her
demonstrate her ability because they're
presenting her is a relatively ambiguous
character she seems pretty nice but
she's not totally down with what team
flash is trying to sell her her sonic
ability looks like it's causing
explosions but in the comics the
Fiddler's ability was more about
hypnosis he hypnotized people by playing
his fiddle so still kind of 50/50 on the
way they're using her powers on the TV
show but the title of the episode is
subject 9 she's the ninth meta that the
thinker has created so it'll be
interesting to see what these final
metas are I know their theories about
the final meta now there are 12 on the
bus but if you didn't see my thinker
final boss form video I talked about the
different minds that the thinker might
enter and what he might do with their
powers like how elongated man is an
important part of him reclaiming his
original body even though there are only
12 bus metas I do think that Barry will
probably be the final meta like there
was a theory that Cecile's baby might be
that final one
but because Caitlin confirmed that it's
not a metahuman I don't think the baby
itself is going to be important for the
thinker heart rates 170 BPM
nope it's a perfectly normal baby
girl you were gonna say baby girl so
twist of all twists berry making the
ultimate chess move and sacrificing
himself to take down the thinker will
technically make him the final meta that
the thinker tries to steal the powers
from we get a new shot of iris and HR
and the flash mobile I'm hoping that if
they send her out on more missions with
team flash related stuff that they just
let her actually shoot people with those
guns because one of the funniest things
that they introduced in the last couple
of seasons is the idea that Joe trained
her to shoot a gun that was the thing
last season before the big final battle
with saboteur hey Stu why'd you do that
as a kid I thought you were so cool
what'd I tell you guns aren't cool just
for protection right I'm glad that they
confirmed that elongated man really is
elongated man too because I get a lot of
questions about that because he has the
elongated man named the elongated man
costume but his powers work more like
plastic man's and they do give a
shout-out to him in Episode four when we
got that elongated man episode when we
first learned about his powers do I get
a cool superhero name what do you think
about Plastic Man I think that's the
dumbest name I've ever heard of yeah
Cisco comes up with the names moving
into Titan Season one territory Doom
Patrol was just confirmed by Geoff Johns
they're literally calling episode 5 the
Doom Patrol so is either going to
introduce them in a flashback or in
present day I'm guessing it's gonna be a
combination of both because Beast Boy
who's a core Titans member used to be a
member of Doom Patrol before he became a
Titan but the Doom Patrol as a team goes
away back to the 60s in the comics just
because of crisis and a lot of the
relaunches that the Doom Patrol team is
at they were never a crazy popular team
in the comics which is why DC tried to
use the team in a bunch of different
ways but the original version of the
team started with the chief who was sort
of their leader his name is Niles
Caulder
robot man Elastigirl in- man and that
was back in the 60s they've already
confirmed that the chief and Elastigirl
are characters coming in present-day
here's what we get into some flash
crossover - this was kind of funny the
other members of the
team that were on with Beast Boy were
elongated man who's obviously a
character on flash season 4 right now
Metamorpho in the female version of
doctor light which we actually got
during flash season 2 even though
technically the character whose doctor
lied in the comics is not Linda Park
so I know there's a lot of questions
about how Titan's is connected to any of
the other DC TV shows the ones on the CW
the ones that are coming to the DC
streaming service but within the world
of the Titans whatever world that is it
sounds like they're gonna be introducing
the idea of the Doom Patrol in the way
that you have say like flash episodes
but you also have team arrow operating
in a different part of the country doing
their own stuff and every once in a
while they crossover
so within season one of Titans Doom
Patrol will get an arc but I don't know
how big their characters are going to be
there are 13 episodes total so I'm
guessing that they're only gonna be
around for a couple episodes during
season one and I think just depending on
how it goes they'll bring people back
usually if things go really well like
people really like the characters or the
story just totally works and the
characters fit really well with the core
Titans then they'll totally bring people
back the current DC TV shows are really
good at doing that especially the flash
anytime there's a fan favorite they
always come back like Jay Garrick will
always come back to the flash reverse
flash will always come back Trigon is
gonna be the ultimate big bat of the
series but I think it's gonna take them
a couple seasons to get to their terror
of Trigon arc that's the one that they
did for the animated Teen Titans movie
where he uses Raven to come into our
world and the Titans had to fight him
off
but in the comics it was a much bigger
thing and it came after several of their
bigger other adventures so brother blood
church' blood will probably be the more
realistic villains of season 1 and then
they'll just tease Trigon towards the
end of the season but I would be very
surprised if you actually got a picture
of his full-on face they might save that
reveal for season 2 I've already done
videos about Hawk and Dove and some of
the other characters that they're doing
so just remember that the Doom Patrol is
not the only team that they're gonna
cross paths with the actor that plays
Beast Boy was posting pictures recently
with Raven they said that there would be
a team reveal relatively soon I think
that they'll post a picture of them in
real life without their makeup on first
together before they do like a
full-blown costume reveal and before we
see an actual trailer so they're getting
ready to film episode 5 and it's a
13-episode season it's probably gonna be
a while before we see that trailer I
don't think till maybe April maybe May
but maybe WonderCon they'll release some
more information they have actually
started posting more
behind-the-scenes stuff because they are
fully into the season so don't worry
there'll be plenty of more Titans
dropping in the next couple of months
for those of you asking about Black
Lightning I'll probably wait till after
the next couple of episodes to post
another video it hasn't been quite as
popular as I would have hoped on my
channel but I haven't completely dropped
the series I am still watching it but
I'll probably just wait a couple weeks
to do another video for that
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Hanson please private message me
so I can get your contact details there
was a new round in this video I'll just
name the winner when I post new DC this
weekend click here for that brand new
Incredibles trailer and click here for
that brand new flash family video thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight